apparently freezing Jello causes it to
crystallize
before we get started I just want to
know which one of you ball head hoochies
is keeping Jello in business So the
instructions say two cups boiling water
two cups cold water that look that's a
lot of one-fourths they got something
floating in it but oh well let's just
let this boil how much of this y'all
think we supposed to use
probably just a little bit
um
boy one time this waste on me when that
woman was twisting my braids I could
have died at seven add in the cold water
transfer the proper amount refrigerate
usually when I be doing stuff like this
I do it wrong and y'all be telling me
cook them on reduced heat we'll be back
[Music]
I'm excited
Jello tastes invisible with a splash of
hairspray
[Music]
ASAP
it wasn't that good I don't even know
why I'm gonna give them a 10.